this is gonna come as no surprise but I
wanted to ask about the MCU
what is the biggest difference between
your original expectations for Laura
when you first signed on for age of
Ultron and where the role wound up going
in endgame or I guess - you know
condense that a little was there ever
any discussions about more for her oh I
mean you know it was one of those things
where I was sort of you know brought
into the universe and it truly is its
own universe it is its own entity with
this fandom that is incredible and to be
part of it is I don't know it's pretty
fun I mean my my daughter's friends love
it it's one of those kinds of things you
know so it's always fun I mean you know
what I love to see a Laura bar movie
sure but I don't think that's gonna
happen I think people are more
interested in the superheroes I don't
think you're alone on that though I'm
seriously like dead serious rooting for
some sort of Marvel movie where it's
where it's more you know grounded
reality based just the day to day life
and I feel like Laura and Clint and
their family would be the perfect way to
explore that yeah I mean it she's the
wife but you could see it in the wife's
perspective right and you could take a
wife role and make it so much more and
then we all win